توصل إلى أن أول أم تبلغ من العمر 17 عامًا وطفلها البالغ من العمر
ستة أشهر من بين ستة
أشخاص قُتلوا في وقت مبكر من صباح يوم الإثنين
في منزل بوسط كاليفورنيا
، حيث تم إطلاق النار على الأم والطفل في
رأس الشرطة يخبرون بالخطيئة ويظهر القتل
أن تكون مرتبطًا بكارتل مخدرات
عندما يبدأ مباشرة برؤية جوش
كامبل يعيش في لوس أنجلوس لشبكة سي إن إن
هذا الصباح ، جوش ، مرحبًا بكم ، ما
الذي تتعلمه عن هذا الهجوم ،
صباح الخير يا دون وسأحذر
مشاهدينا من أن ما أقوم به  أنا على وشك
أن أصفه هو رسم ومثير للقلق ، وسأطلعك
على الجدول الزمني وتقول الشرطة إنه في
ساعة الصباح الباكر أمس حوالي
الساعة الثالثة صباحًا ، يتلقون مكالمة 9-1-1
من مطلق النار النشط في هذا السكن
في مقاطعة تولاري والذي  على بعد حوالي ثلاث
ساعات شمال لوس أنجلوس الآن
أرسلوا نوابهم ، يستغرق الأمر
عدة دقائق للوصول إلى هناك ، فهذه
منطقة نائية وبينما هم في
طريقهم إلى مسرح الجريمة هذا ،
يتلقى المرسل مكالمات 9-1-1 أخرى تقول
نحن نسمع  طلقة تلو الأخرى
عندما وصلت السلطات أخيرًا ،
لم يعثروا على مشتبه به ، لكنهم وجدوا
مسرح جريمة مروعة تقول السلطات
إنه كان هناك ستة أشخاص على الأقل
قتلوا بينهم شخصان
قُتلا خارج المنزل أحدهم
كان في المدخل  كما
ذكرت أمًا تبلغ من العمر 17 عامًا وطفلة تبلغ من
العمر ست سنوات في الرأس ، فإن الجهود
جارية في هذه الساعة من قبل الشرطة
لمحاولة العثور على المسؤولين ،
وقد تعرفت الشرطة على المشتبه به جوش
حسنًا لقد تحدثت مؤخرًا  ليلة مع مسؤول
من مكتب الشريف الذي يقول
إنهم يصفون هذا بأنه
تنفيذ على غرار كارتل وماذا يعني ذلك
أننا نعلم أن عصابات الشوارع في الولايات المتحدة
غالبًا ما تنخرط في أعمال عنف ولكن هذا
الوصف أه تنفيذًا شبيهًا بالكارتل
يوحي  مستوى مكثف من
الوحشية والتطور ، نعلم
أن عصابات المخدرات المكسيكية ، على سبيل المثال ،
قد انخرطت في أعمال عنف فظيعة
ضد أعدائها
المتصورين إلى حد نشر فرق الاغتيال  تحدث العمدة
بالأمس عن من يعتقدون
أنهم يبحثون عنه ، استمع ،
نعتقد أن لدينا اثنين من المشتبه بهم على الأقل
في هذه المرحلة ، ونعتقد أيضًا أن هذا
ليس عملاً عشوائيًا من أعمال العنف
نعتقد أن هذه كانت عائلة مستهدفة
ونعتقد أنها  هناك ثماني
جمعيات متورطة في هذا المشهد ،
لذا قال اثنان على الأقل من المشتبه بهما ،
إنهما يبحثان عنهما ، ومن
المهم فقط ملاحظة أنهما ما
زالا يحاولان تجميع كل هذا معًا
بالنظر إلى أغلفة القذائف التي تعرفها في عملية جمع
الأصوات للشهود إذا  لقد سمعوا
أي شيء حول تلك المنطقة بشكل مثير للاهتمام
دون قبل أسبوع واحد أن المسكن نفسه
كان موضوع أمر تفتيش
وقضية المخدرات ، لذلك
تبحث الشرطة لتحديد ما إذا كان كل هذا
مرتبطًا أو